also würde entweder ich sterben wollen
oder zwei andere personen dass sich die
für mich sterben lasse hallo ich mit
meiner liebe freuen und herzlich
willkommen hier zu einer weiteren folge
halten sie ich habe wieso freunde kann
mir das mal jemand erklären wieso hat
man bei haydn zu kaufhof immer den blog
jetzt so in sich drin ich kann nur so um
laufen ohne dass es mega bescheuert aus
sie ich habe mir gedacht wir machen
heute mal wieder so eine fragt luca
runde wo ich einfach gechillt ein paar
fragen beantworten und zwar habe ich
gestern abend bei twitter wieder gefragt
hey schreibt mir unter den hashtag fragt
luca ein paar sachen falls irgendwelche
fragen habt oder so da kamen viele
fragen an ganz interessante fragen auch
und ich suche jetzt mal eben erst mal
den osc im wasser gelandet möchte den
dänen den diesmal suchen den sie kann
dass der mich irgendwie mal tötet davon
ist das ist noch ein blog ich möchte
sterben ich möchte sicher sei dass die
behinderten naja aber wir fangen jetzt
mit der ersten frage die wurde mir
nämlich zugesendet von kraft jannik wie
sieht's aus mit dem studium dsds beende
oder machst du youtube zu seinem
hauptberuf
ich werde auf jeden fall das studium
beenden ich werde das denke ich
irgendwie unter einen hut kriegen
zusammen noch mit mit youtube das
irgendwie fertig zu machen
auch die klausurphase ist jetzt erst mal
wenn ihr das video seht wahrscheinlich
schon vorbei hier töte mich mal danke
danke
also ich werde das studium auf jeden
fall beenden
youtube zum hauptberuf machen habe ich
ja schon sehr oft gesagt werde ich
wahrscheinlich nicht weil ich halt
studiere und dann werde ich später einen
beruf ausüben und youtube solange
nebenher laufen lassen wie es mir spaß
macht weil ich möchte kein hobby zum
beruf machen weil ich finde ein hobby
hat man angefangen weil es einem spaß
macht und werden es dann ein beruf ist
dann muss man es ja weitermachen weil
man damit ja sein geld verdient versteht
was ich meine also das heißt ich will
jetzt nicht dass das youtube irgendwann
mir nur noch spaß macht weil mir keinen
spaß macht aber ich muss das noch
weitermachen weil ich damit quasi mein
geld verdiene wenn ihr versteht was ich
meine frage zwei kommen von selb xf tief
wie die oder so bildest du er dich für
zwei fremde person entscheiden zu
sterben oder sie für dich sterben lassen
es ist eine frage die ich daran genommen
hat weil das eigentlich eine total
komische frage ist also würde entweder
ich sterben wollen oder zwei andere
personen dass sich die für mich sterben
lasse es ist
so ein bisschen komisch formuliert aber
ich denke dass es im menschen seien so
verankert dass man immer für sich selber
das beste möchte und wenn zwei fremde
personen die ich nicht kenne haben
müssten damit ich weiter lebe würde ich
das natürlich machen wenn das
familienmitglieder von mir wären wenn
jetzt so irgendwie sagen wir mit vier
familienmitglieder entweder sterben
viele leute aus meiner familie oder ich
würde sterben dann würde ich mich
natürlich für die familie entscheiden
weil ich die halt kenne aber wenn jetzt
irgendwie so zwei fremde personen
stellen müssen
es könnten ja rein theoretisch auch wenn
ich gar nicht kenne es können auch
irgendwelche bösen menschen sein die
tausende leute umgebracht haben also ich
denke dass ich auf jeden fall weiter
erleben möchte wenn ihr die frage
richtig verstandener wohl nur fragt
hashtag fragt luca wie sieht eigentlich
aus mit dieser ins netz gehen sache und
was für reaktionen hast du auf dein
video bekommen ich habe ja damals ein
video gemacht wo ich über eine website
geredet hat wo man testen kann ob man
internetsüchtig ist
und da ist bei mir selber herausgekommen
dass ich ein wenig internet süchtig bin
natürlich weil ich das meistens ja auch
youtube mache ich ja auch so als
nebenjob quasi so als als hobby nebenbei
deswegen bin ich auch deswegen meistens
im internet aber bei mir kam das halt
trotzdem raus dass sich halt internet
gefährdet gefährdet zur wichtigkeit bin
also nicht so wichtig aber ich bin
gefährt da haben mir echt extrem viele
leute darunter geschrieben ich hatte
erst angst dass wenn ich so was
eventuell mal erwähnt würde dass leute
sagen hey was soll das denn hier
befindet sich im internet können nicht
verraten oder irgendwie sowas in die
richtung aber die sache war halt dass
viele leute nicht zu ihre story station
die kommentare geschrieben haben also
viele meint echt zu jahr
ich hab den test gemacht und ich bin
angeblich internetsüchtig ich werde auf
jeden fall was dran ändern und so etwas
freut mich einfach wenn ich leute mit
sowas nicht beeinflussen kann aber mit
so was quasi zum nachdenken bringen kann
weil es ist halt wirklich so die
tatsache wenn man lange vom pc sitzen so
der rücken verkrümmt sich und was ich
alles und ich hab selber dieses
selbstexperiment jetzt mal gemacht in
letzter zeit und zwar bin ich ja zurzeit
in der klausurphase das heißt die
scheibe drei personen zwei wochen und
waren den zwei wochen nur am pc wenn ich
wirklich ein video aufgenommen weil sie
zum beispiel jetzt gerade ist 13 uhr
ich bin um 9 uhr aufgestanden heute habt
gelernt gelernt habe den den jazz laden
hier richtig zum laufen gebracht und so
jedenfalls war ich in der zeit hat so
selten wie möglich am pc und habe
einfach geschaut ob ich das kann ob ich
mich einfach auf den schreibtisch setzen
kann ohne pc an zu machen
im internet zu sein ohne irgendwie
hatten im internet zu machen oder so
sondern mich einfach nur vom pc setzen
und lernen und es das habe ich echt
nicht hingekriegt und deswegen würde ich
echt sagen
also ich weiss nicht bei mir zumindest
ich weiß gar nicht dass diese frage gab
ziel also die reaktion auf das video
waren auf jeden fall positiv und ich bin
überrascht davon wie viele leute wieder
ihre ergebnis wirklich gesagt haben weil
ich hätte echt gedacht dass viele sagen
nee ich möchte es nicht sagt beispiel
rauskommen ist oder sich einfach gar
nicht dazu äußern oder so weil sie
selbst einsehen dass sie internet
gefährdet sind süchtig zu werden oder so
aber es ist auf jeden fall mega
interessant was dafür ergebnis herauskam
wir sind jetzt schon aus der runde auch
so wenn ihr das video nicht kennt ich
habe einen link in der beschreibung zu
dem video wo ich das richtig erklärt
habe zu dieser internet gucken sache ob
man süchtig ist und da ist auch noch mal
so einen link drin wo ich selber diesen
test machen könnt wenn ihr das machen
wollt ihr müsst ihr natürlich drauf
klicken
aber das ist ganz interessant weil man
selber schauen kann was mit seinem
konsumverhalten vom internet dann begibt
man als ein paar fragen an soja ich
sitze und solange pc ich würde lieber
game cod spielen statt mit freunden zu
treffen oder so und das ist schon ganz
interessant was da dann quasi so für
ergebnis herauskommen das kann man
einfach mal machen also ich fand es zum
beispiel mega interessant als ich das
gemacht habe ihn an fragt was würdest du
ohne kran crafter und pixel wolf machen
das ist natürlich sehr persönliche frage
ob ich denke ich wirklich grundsätzlich
erstmal besser führen weil die beiden
total voll sparten sind sie halt echt
noch mal aufgefallen als die hier als
wir alle zu dritt in nach köln gefahren
sind
das war echt so weiß ich nicht das war
mega anstrengen mit den beiden somit
justin alleine alles will ich mit max
alleine alles chilis ohne die beiden im
paket das ist so wie weiß ich nicht
irgendwie das ist sowie mit essen glaube
ich so ein burger ist so richtig gut
schmeckt so lecker dann so eine portion
gemüse oder so kann auch mal richtig gut
schmecken aber wenn du beides zusammen
mixed in mixa packs und das dann trinkt
diese masse dann ist es richtig abartig
so in etwa ist das mit dem ball der wind
fragt hashtag frage hättest immer bock
auf ein anderes pc spiele zu zocken wie
zum beispiel happy meals die sache ist
dass ich ja immer schon so ab und zu ein
paar spiele zocken
also so iphone spiele es regnet in der
lobby das hatte ich auch noch nie hatte
ich zocke ich ja schon immer mal so ein
bisschen andere spieler also meistens
dann auf dem handy irgendwie demnächst
kommt zum beispiel monster legends
wollte ich mal spielen daraus etwas
kleinere serie machen oder so wenn das
vielleicht gefällt dann habe ich zum
beispiel jetzt auch letztes jahr dieses
moneygram gespielt irgendwie vor ein
paar tagen ich weiß nicht genau wann ich
dieses video heraus bringen deswegen
weil es gerade nicht ganz genau wann ich
letztes mal sowas gespielt habt dann
habe ich noch so andere spiele gespielt
wie beispielsweise dort ab oder so also
ich spiele ja immer so ein paar andere
spieler außer minecraft aber pc spiele
jetzt irgendwie sowas wie happy meals
wird in zukunft denke ich auch noch
kommen weil ich mir echt gesagt habe ich
möchte in zukunft mehr so andere spiele
außer minecraft spielen am besten kann
man ja mal sehen ob euch ein video
gefällt oder nicht anhand der
bewertungen und auch anhand der clicks
also wenn man dann so schaut okay wie
viele klicks hat das wieviel bewertungen
hat das in etwa ob da jetzt die leute
sagen ja das ist spitze
dann geben wir natürlich für den daumen
hoch oder nächstes nicht so gegeben er
mehr leute daumen runter
deswegen habe ich mir dann einfach mal
so gedacht sojakomplex immer was für
gefällt den leuten da denn mehr was auf
was könnten die eventuell mehr stehen
ich lasse mir wieder direkt umbringen
weil ich mag es viel lieber wenn ich
wenn ich sie kabine sommerrunde
jedenfalls habe ich dann geschaut wie es
den leuten so gefällt und das ist echt
so dass den leuten voll oft einfach das
dings besser gefällt so wenn ich andere
spieler mache aus minecraft als
minecraft selbst und deswegen habe ich
mir gedacht dass ich in zukunft
natürlich immer noch minecraft bringen
aber auch viele so andere spiele also
mal ganz unterschiedliche sachen das war
ein bisschen abwechslung immer ist und
darauf habe ich auf jeden fall auf
megawatt games fragt wann streams du das
nächste mal hashtags luca das ist eine
ganz interessante entwicklung zurzeit am
laufen und zwar wie gesagt ich weiß
nicht wann ihr das video schaut und ob
es dann schon bin aber ich bin zurzeit
am schauen dass ich irgendwie twitch
partner werde und dass sich damit dann
auch andere funktionen nutzen kann wie
beispielsweise dass ich dann
irgendwie smileys in chat packen kann
und was weiß ich noch alles was man da
als partner so alles machen kann
da bin ich auf jeden fall zeit so ein
bisschen am plan mit meinem netzwerk das
wir da schauen dass wir da schauen auf
jeden fall wie man wie ich das da machen
könnte ob ich dass sich partner werde
habe ich denn schon getötet jetzt ist er
wieder da ist er
der pitcher jetzt habe ich den
durchschaue auf jeden fall dass sich in
zukunft irgendwann tritsch partner werde
und dann werden vielleicht auch häufiger
streams kommen aber natürlich nur wenn
ich nicht in der klausurphase bin zum
beispiel derzeit ist halt einfach drei
wochen nur klausuren
deswegen kam es in letzter zeit nicht so
viel streams aber es hat mir einfach
mega spaß gemacht so zu streamen wie das
dann auch richtig funktioniert somit mit
internet und allem dass man eine gute
leitung hat das erste mal oder die
erstmalige stream bat ich halt diese
16.000 anleitungen damit kommt man halt
überhaupt nicht online spielen wir jetzt
diesen letzten stream den ich da gemacht
habe
der war auf jeden fall wird mir richtig
gut gefallen weil ich da einfach mit
euch interagieren konnte ich konnte alle
fenster nebenbei offen haben ohne dass
ich da irgendwie totale frame einbußen
hatte oder irgendwie sowas in der
richtung deswegen war ich dachte schon
deswegen wird auf jeden fall in nächster
zeit erst mal häufiger gestreamt laura
fragt was würdest du lieber aufgeben
youtube oder deine freunde also die
sache ist halt dass ich mit von youtube
jetzt nicht mit so vielen leuten abhänge
weil ich jetzt halt nicht youtube
hauptberuflich machen nicht den ganzen
tag meine ganze zeit in youtube stecke
sondern halt echt viel mit leuten mache
die ich von der schule kenne von der uni
kenne und mit denen halt viel unterwegs
bin
deswegen denke ich die für die youtube
aufgeben weil freunde finde ich ist
somit das wichtigste ohne freunde macht
das leben keinen spaß und
ja also ich denke ich wird wenn schon
wenn ich mich entscheiden müsste
zwischen freunden und youtube würde ich
auf jeden fall freunde nehmen weil ich
denke natürlich macht youtube spaß und
so aber einfach jeden tag nur videos
machen alleine und so ohne freunde das
ist glaube ich schon ein bisschen blöd
haust du ab und zu auch die handball-wm
fragt schon wieder ein kevin alter wie
viele kämen stellen fragen
ich schaue jetzt nicht so dass ich mir
sage holzspiel deutschland ich schalte
dann holt man den fernseher ein und
schaue handball-wm sondern es ist halt
meist ist einfach so dass wir in
irgendeiner bar sind oder wir sitzen in
der uni oder so und dann läuft gerade
auf dem fernseher halt handball-wm dann
schaut man einmal drauf und ich weiß
auch gar nicht so viel darüber ich weiß
nur dass deutschland relativ gut am
rasieren ist und deutschen auf jeden
fall
hoffentlich irgendwie weltmeister wird
das wäre auf jeden fall richtig geil und
ja das hoffe ich auf jeden fall
er kann es sein dass dieser lucy das
nämlich verfolgt wenn ich jetzt hier
reingehen kommt er auch hier rein wenn
ich hier rein hier kommt er auch hier
rein wahrscheinlich verstehe nicht was
das soll
ohne witz das ist zwar cool und so dass
sie mich erkennt aber das ist so unnötig
weil wir halt einfach ein spiel spielen
und er hält sich an die regel lucy spiel
doch einfach das spiel man das ist doch
dumm stemmer vor 12 games oder so oder
nie hier ist echt so am besten so alle
verstecken sich und alle anderen das
hatten wir letzten sieg in der letzten
freiburger folge dass du fünf leute um
mich herum stehen und sie zeigen hey i
kenn dich als kollegen
also ja ich auch ab und zu aber jetzt
nicht dass ich da wirklich so sagen ja
ich spiele ich schalte den fernseher nur
für handball wm und so aber wir kommen
hier schon zur letzten frage und zwar
nils schreibt super bowl prognose
und da muss wirklich sagen ich habe
dieses jahr die letzten jahre immer sehr
viel nfl geguckt auch mit diesem nfl ps
kann man sich glaube ich kaufen
aber dieses jahr würde ich sagen die
die hawks gewinnen weil ich mit denen
einfach mehr sympathisieren und die
haben besseren fenster finde ich aber
jetzt genau wer die meisten punkte hat
und die meisten touchdowns und was weis
ich habe nicht so viel ahnung von
fussball ich bin ein bisschen ich mag
den sport und so aber ich denke die
seahawks werden gewinnen einfach mehr
sympathisiere
und das war's dann auch schon damit die
nachfolge von luca ihr findet in der
beschreibung links zu meinem twitter
wenn eben auch fragen habt ihr findet
link zu dieser internet sache wo ihr
selber diese den test machen können ob
ihr abhängigkeit wird ob ihr gefährdet
seit oder irgend sowas ist ganz
interessant so was rauskommt teilweise
und das finde ich alles in der
beschreibung wenn es euch gefallen habe
ich mich um eine bewertung freuen dass
es einen klick der einfach der preis auf
video draufkleben dann sehen wir
zunächst mal wieder